is their attention though when you are
having these conversations between what
Carl said which is adding your name to
it because I think years ago for example
I think it was a conversation he'll way
before our time about should colleges
layer the name of donors I know it was
in my time well that was me okay and the
colleges do not bear the name of donors
but other things do like the best
library the Jackson institution and
others given what Carl just said which
is students may have a feeling of
altering their life's choices based on
that is their attention and how do those
conversations actually go I can see that
there could be attention I can see that
you know when you are surrounded by
these big names etc that you know it
might be a little bit intimidating or an
expectation but you know the other thing
is that we have had philanthropists
here's whose name is not on anything so
one always has the choice of giving
anonymously or privately if one wants to
escape that you know if this person did
that and I ought to be doing that but
you know in Germany that debate is also
you know when people give their Germany
does not have a culture of philanthropy
at lies not in the American sense but
they are trying to introduce this now
and so a big issue is you know
significant donors there are significant
donors but very few admit to it so you
my alma mater is the University of
Heidelberg so you get an announcement
from there that they are being able to
do this that or the other because of a
gift and that's all and you wonder what
can I believe here you know transparency
so if somebody is willing to put their
name on the gift that helps everybody i
know we always say it helps you know
encouraging other people to give that's
one thing
but you also want to know you know where
does the University get the resources
from to do what it is doing I think that
sense of transparency is very important
so I am for names on buildings but I
respect everybody's desire to be private
about it anonymous about it but it is
you know there are many dimensions to to
this question